well it's about time Apple it only took
you 14 versions to catch up but you
finally did it
what's going on guys my name's Dave
atomic welcome back to the channel today
we're talking about the brand new
version of iPad OS 14 OS 14 and
absolutely everything to do with the
WWDC 2020 if you're new to the tech
space and first of all have no idea what
WWDC 2020 stands for it stands for the
Worldwide Developers Conference in 2020
this is an Apple hosted event that was
for the first time ever hosted over the
worldwide Internet usually it is a
face-to-face conference with tickets
costing upwards of fifteen hundred US
dollars however because of the whole
kovin 19 pandemic Apple is opted for the
online only experience absolutely free
of charge so this time around we've had
hundreds and hundreds of developers and
tech fanatics like myself be able to
tune in to the WWDC and experience
absolutely everything there for example
right now I have the iPad OS 14 up and
running on a 6th gen iPad in front of me
the 6th gen iPad is able to run OS 14
without a problem on the list every
single device that is expected to be
able to run iOS 14 when it launches
officially later in September or October
this year right now the version running
on my iPad is the developers beta the
developers beta is available for all
individuals who wish to pay the
developers beta costs of I believe it is
99 US dollars or you can find yourself a
free developers beta at the link below
now just quickly I have no affiliation
to this site it is just where I managed
to find my developers beta to download
and utilize for the purposes of this
video now I've spent the last day
playing around with iOS 14 and all
new features and functions that are
available to this device obviously
everything on an iPad is slightly
different to what is available on an
iPhone there are some key differences
but overall is predominantly the same
let's start with the biggest and most
talked-about feature and that is the
widgets on the side panel so if you're
an iPad user unfortunately right now in
the beta's developers version you can
only have the widgets in the today
section of the menu which permanently is
not on the screen you cannot drag and
drop these widgets onto the homescreen
into positions like you can on the
iPhone now this is something that I'm
hoping will change in the future because
it would be nice to have these widgets
on your home screen on an iPad
especially with that much much larger
real estate however at the time being as
this is recorded which is let me just
check the date the 28th of June at 8:33
p.m. there is no implementation of the
widgets onto the home screen on the iPad
OS what it does have on the other hand
is the same three widget system that the
iPhone has it features a small medium
and a large widget for a selected
variety of apps at the moment there
isn't too many available on the iPad
that is predominantly for the fact that
it's brand-new just released but more
and more developers will come to the
party at the moment Apple has noted in
their developing guidelines that the
small widget which is actually most of
my widgets on this iPad if I'm being
honest this is technically considered a
small widget when you tap on it it
automatically opens up the app it does
not open up as a button or as a feature
so for example if I were to scroll down
here to the larger widget which gives me
more information about my activity on
this iPad and you just tap on Safari or
whatever it opens it directly to that
feature something that has changed the
predominant way an iPhone user use
their iPhone is the app library now the
app library is an automatic accumulation
of all your apps grouped together by
what I'm assuming is an algorithm and
automatically distributed into different
folders for your convenience
it is usually located at the very end of
your pages which now you can also hide
but we'll get to that in a second
unfortunately with the iPad OS there is
no app library so it doesn't matter how
far we swipe across there is absolutely
no app library this is a bit of a
letdown considering that more people
would have larger storage space on their
iPad more apps more games more diversity
in what they have and it would be a nice
little additional feature maybe we will
see this in the full release maybe right
but for the time being it is not in the
iPad OS another thing that isn't
available on the iPad but it is
available on iPhone OS is the simple
fact that you can hide pages from your
view so usually if you're an iPhone user
or you have anything like me you have a
ton of apps sitting in a random folder
or a ton of apps sitting on another page
hidden at the back of your iPhone now
you can actually go into what Apple has
claimed it jiggle mode I just go into
jiggle mode and automatically activate
and deactivate different pages of your
iPhone so if you have 10 pages to scroll
through to get to the back one you can
now just hide all nine of them so you
only have your main pages that you need
and switch to the app library when you
need it now obviously if you're an
Android user this has been a thing for
decades and it's nothing new it is how
we operate it is how the system has been
designed but having said that Apple has
done this in their own unique little way
Android has had widgets time and time
again
whereas iPhone and
has now introduced the stacked widgets
so stacked widgets is a very Apple way
of developing in a very Apple way of
creating a new feature so stacking
widgets allows you to literally do that
stack your favorite widgets one on top
of the other in order to create your
favorite stack and then you can quickly
just swipe through them to get all the
notifications you need that way you
don't take up all the real estate and
you get all the functionality of it
something I'd definitely like to see on
an Android but for now I'm happy that
it's on the iPad now another feature
that's unique to the iPad is an update
to the Apple pencil if you're a user
like me who uses the Apple pencil all
the time and you have a tendency to
write text more than you have to type so
for me personally I'm usually in a
meeting taking notes this is the easiest
and quickest way for me to take notes
without really disrupting the meeting
and acting in a professional manner for
me it's just write notes keep talking
and keep conducting the meeting whereas
if I were typing constantly I'd be
looking down shifting changing and it'd
be a little bit more inappropriate a
good thing that has come to Apple iPad
OS 14 now is scribble-scribble allows
you to write like you normally would
with a pencil but it automatically
translates that into text I've been
having a good go at this for a solid two
hours as I was scribbling different
things to see how it would work and
honestly it's pretty good my handwriting
is not the best but it is able to
capture most of what I write if I take a
little bit of time to slow down and
articulate my words properly then it
definitely captures almost every single
word I wrote the good thing is if you're
an artist or just somebody having a play
with shapes and features if you start
drawing a shape and pause just before
you finish it it'll automatically detect
that shape and create the perfect shape
for you
so for example I'm right-handed but to
draw a perfect circle with my left hand
is now
very easy so a very simple feature that
should have been introduced a long time
ago but as technology improves obviously
so do the things that go with it
this is a feature I'm very excited to
continue using and look forward to
seeing in the full release of iOS 14 now
if you haven't really understood the
theme so far it's a whole refresh of the
UI the UI has gotten a lot sleeker a lot
more compact a lot more elegant and in
my opinion a lot more Apple there's been
a redesign from the iPad to the iWatch 2
TV system all the way through the larger
updates of their operating system of
their Mac books and Mac computers so
what you'll notice now is if you get a
call for example it used to take up your
whole iPhone screen now instead there'll
only be a little bit of a drop down from
the top that you can swipe away or
answer depending on what you want to do
with that call which doesn't disrupt
your complete workflow the same thing
goes with Siri Siri used to open up and
dominate your entire screen whereas now
if we just go hey Siri it's a little bit
slow but it only opens up in the bottom
corner what you will also notice is up
in the top a little orange icon appears
next to the Wi-Fi symbol on the iPad now
what that means is the fact that the
microphone is active if that orange
light were to go green for example it
means an application is using your
camera so this is a great way to manage
the privacy on your device if something
is using your microphone or your camera
in the background that you aren't aware
of it is very very simple to understand
now that something is using it even
though Siri has gotten a more compact
much more minimalistic appearance
unfortunately it isn't utilizable in a
multitasking way so
Siri is in the bottom corner or only
taking up a tiny portion of your iPhone
screen you'd think that you'd be able to
use the
ground apps and continue scrolling at
your Safari page for example well note
unfortunately once you tap away from
Syria or try to scroll it completely
remove Siri and gets on with the app
you're using before something that can
be used simultaneously is
picture-in-picture mode something that
has been around on an android for
decades but we won't get into that
picture-in-picture mode now allows you
to for example if you're watching a full
screen video get out of that video going
to your notes type a quick note come
back to that video or if you're in
FaceTime get out of FaceTime find the
phone number and then tell them that
phone number directly in a smaller
picture and picture you can resize move
from one corner to another anywhere in
the screen that you like whereas
previously it would close out of that
app open another app pause your FaceTime
Rives resume the FaceTime later on and
it would just be a nightmare so now it's
definitely a much easier much more
native picture-in-picture mode that is a
great addition to iOS 14 something that
hasn't been spoken about iOS 14 too
often on YouTube is the integration of
iOS 14 and air pods this is actually
something really cool and something I am
definitely jealous of as an Android user
yes Android has this but not as good so
with the new air pods you're going to
have the ability of smart switching now
what this means is that the Bluetooth in
your ear pods and the connectivity
between your Apple devices all talk to
each other so if you're sitting there
watching something on your iPad with
your ear pods in you put your iPad down
you go over there you grab up your
iPhone and you start doing another video
on your iPhone your ear pods will
automatically switch to that iPhone
audio instead of the iPad audio you had
going on before this also works if
you're on your iPhone and then switch to
your macbook and vice versa this is
something that makes transitioning your
Bluetooth headphones so so easy it is
definitely definitely a useful feature
and something that you realize is
incredible without
realizing it another little feature that
has changed slightly but it is quite
noticeable if you're paying attention to
detail the new update has increased the
saturation and brightness of your device
so your blacks have gotten richer and
darker and your whites have gotten
crisper all your colors have become more
vibrant and cleaner it isn't something
that you're going to notice unless you
pay attention
for example the Notes app the black is
now truly black it isn't a dulled out
gray anymore so this is just a simple
change but again it is moving into that
new style that new Apple way and that
new Apple branding one downside of the
beta version of iOS 14 though is the
fact that it is actually chewing my
battery a little bit quicker than I like
it too I don't know if it's just the
beta if it's some bugs early on but it
is definitely going through the battery
in about an hour and a half I've lost
about 30% so an iPad not so great
usually I'd get maybe about 30% more
than that
so it isn't terrible but it is
noticeable anyway that's all I've had
the liberty of playing around with on
iPad OS 14 and iOS 14 if you have any
questions about the software how to
install it how to find out all the extra
features or really something more
specific about the software feel free to
leave a comment down below I reply to as
many people as I can thank you so much
for watching I truly do hope you enjoyed
the video if you did make sure you smash
that subscribe button
20:20 style and as always I see you next
Monday